from our investigators a woman accused  of her seventh DUI did not appear in  time for court this morning a judge had  released Marion Reyes Rivero because  prosecutors had not filed charges two  weeks ago well in court today  prosecutors said they still had yet to  file charges due to what they said was a  delay at the Henderson crime lab  it informed us that all be understood  the police department Labs scientists  that are employed at that lab for out of  town this week at a all at the same time  yes sir how did a conference  a city spokesperson telling us that is  not correct and DUI related testing is  not impacted now a judge had previously  ordered Reyes Rivero not to drive as he  is awaited as he awaited the charging  documents record shows she arrived to  court late for the hearing now a hearing  is scheduled in two weeks